this morning husband's brother Muhammad  called and he told us that he was not  able to convince his mother to give her  blessings I'm heartbroken because the  clocks running  I don't have many more days it's been ma  days menses we've been to mummies the  truth is no to this but Muhammad  suggested that we go to mosque with  mommy and pray he thinks this will help  because she is a devout Muslim so that  is where we're going but I I don't know  what to expect this is rude  this is the road okay  I'm nervous about seeing your mom she  care for me the first time I'm having my  doubts she's going to like me a second  time but I have no option I must take  you to her because it will be painful  for both of us  if we leave this town without getting up  listen I want to go to America so I will  do anything possible to make sure that  it will happen so bringing these three  mugs I pray and hope this shoe walk  [Music]